never snap to guides we want your mind
we don't want your software
everybody loves your work you're playing
it much too safe
if you need some people not liking it
then you're probably on to something
the big part of graphic design is to get
somebody to pick up your book to click
on your site to walk across the street
and read the fine print
whoa if you've done your job as a
designer people will do that
in this class i'll be showing my work
and explaining why it looks the way it
does
we'll look at color and shape and
texture and
type what appears chaotic or random is
almost never the case i'm also going to
bring you a design workshop
i give frequently around the world
giving assignments that you can do at
home
the answer to everything you're working
on is within the stuff you're given from
a client
you're going to have some reaction and
then go with that
i never set out to break rules i don't
go to a studio and say okay what rules
can i break today
how can i make this hard to read or you
don't know it's
what am i trying to solve what am i
trying to say what am i feeling and what
does that look like
there's so much slick fine professional
forgettable
graphic design out there there's even
more reason we need a few rebels to make
something stand out
just the form sends a message try not to
get too literal i want to feel that as
much as we see it
trust your eye trust your intuition
every now and then something you weren't
expecting happens in the process
you gotta just trust your gut and do
what you feel
is right and that's where the really
great works come from
i'm david carson and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you